do you ever think about what would
happen if the world were a little bit
different how your life would be
different if you were born five thousand
years from now instead of today how
history would be different if the
continents were at different latitudes
or how life in the solar system would
have developed if the Sun were 10%
larger well playing with these kinds of
possibilities is what I get to do for a
living but with the entire universe I
make model universes in a computer
digital universes that have different
starting points and are made of
different amounts of different kinds of
material and then I compare these
universes to our own to see what it is
made of and how it evolved this process
of testing models with measurements of
the sky has taught us a huge amount
about our universe so far one of the
strangest things we have learned is that
most of the material in the universe is
made of something entirely different
than you and me but without it the
universe as we know it wouldn't exist
everything we can see with telescopes
makes up just about 15% of the total
mass in the universe everything else 85%
of it doesn't emit or absorb light we
can't see it with our eyes we can't
detect it with radio waves or microwaves
or any other kind of light but we know
it is there
because of its influence on what we can
see it's a little bit like if you wanted
to map the surface of our planet and
everything on it using this picture of
the Earth from space at night you get
some clues from where the light is but
there's a lot that you can't see
everything from people to mountain
ranges and you have to infer
what is there from these limited Clues
we call this unseen stuff dark matter
now a lot of people have heard of dark
matter but even if you have heard of it
it probably seems abstract far away
probably even irrelevant well the
interesting thing is dark matter is all
around us and probably right here in
fact dark matter particles are probably
going through your body right now as you
sit in this room because we are on earth
and earth is spinning around the Sun and
the Sun is hurtling through our galaxy
at about half a million miles per hour
but Dark Matter doesn't bump into us it
just goes right through us so how do we
figure out more about this what is it
and what does it have to do with our
existence well in order to figure out
how we came to be we first need to
understand how our galaxy came to be
this is a picture of our galaxy the
Milky Way today what did it look like 10
billion years in the past or what would
it look like 10 billion years in the
future
what about the stories of the hundreds
of millions of other galaxies that we've
already mapped out with large surveys of
the sky how would their histories be
different if the universe was made of
something else or if there was more or
less matter in it so the interesting
thing about these model universes is
that they allow us to test these
possibilities let's go back to the first
moment of the universe just a fraction
of a second after the Big Bang in this
first moment there was no matter at all
the universe was expanding very fast and
quantum mechanics tells us that matter
is being created and destroyed all the
time in every moment
at this time the universe was expanding
so fast that the matter that got created
couldn't get destroyed and thus we think
that all of the matter was created
during this time both the dark matter
and the regular matter that makes up you
and me now let's go a little bit further
to a time after the matter was created
after protons and neutrons formed after
hydrogen formed about four hundred
thousand years after the Big Bang the
universe was hot and dense and really
smooth but not perfectly smooth this
image taken with a space telescope
called the Planck satellite shows us the
temperature of the universe in all
directions and what we see is that there
were places that were a little bit
hotter and denser than others the spots
in this image represent places where
there was more or less mass in the early
universe those spots got big because of
gravity the universe was expanding and
getting less dense overall over the last
13.8 billion years but gravity worked
hard in those spots where there was a
little bit more mass and pulled more and
more mass into those regions now all of
this is a little hard to imagine so let
me just show you what I am talking about
those computer models I mentioned allow
us to test these ideas so let's take a
look at one of them this movie made by
my research group shows us what happened
to the universe after its earliest
moments you see the universe started out
pretty smooth but there were some
regions where there was a little bit
more material gravity turned on and
brought more and more mass into those
spots that started out with a little bit
extra over time you get enough stuff in
one place that the hydrogen gas which
was initially well mixed with the dark
matter starts to separate from it cool
down form stars
and you get a small galaxy over time
over billions and billions of years
those small galaxies crash into each
other and merge and grow to become
larger galaxies like our own galaxy the
Milky Way now what happens if you don't
have dark matter if you don't have dark
matter those spots never get clumpy
enough it turns out you need at least a
million times the mass of the Sun in one
dense region before you can start
forming stars and without dark matter
you never get enough stuff in one place
so here we're looking at two universes
side by side in one of them you can see
that things get clumpy quickly in that
universe it's really easy to form
galaxies in the other universe the
things that start out like small clumps
they just stay really small not very
much happens in that universe you
wouldn't get our galaxy or any other
galaxies you wouldn't get the Milky Way
you wouldn't get the Sun you wouldn't
get us we just couldn't exist in that
universe okay so this crazy stuff dark
matter it's most of the mass in the
universe it's going through us right now
we wouldn't be here without it what is
it well we have no idea but we have a
lot of educated guesses and a lot of
ideas for how to find out more so most
physicists think that dark matter is a
particle similar in many ways to the
subatomic particles that we know of like
protons and neutrons and electrons
whatever it is it behaves very similarly
with respect to gravity but it doesn't
emit or absorb light and it goes right
through normal matter as if it wasn't
even there we'd like to know what
particle it is for example how heavy is
it or does anything at all happen if it
interacts with normal matter
physicists have lots of great ideas for
what it could be they're very creative
but it's really hard because those ideas
span a huge range it could be as small
as the smallest subatomic particles or
it could be as large as the mass of a
hundred Suns so how do we figure out
what it is
well physicists and astronomers have a
lot of ways to look for dark matter one
of the things we're doing is building
sensitive detectors in deep underground
mines waiting for the possibility that a
Dark Matter particle which goes through
us and the earth would hit a denser
material and leave behind some trace of
its passage we're looking for dark
matter in the sky for the possibility
that dark matter particles would crash
into each other and create high-energy
light that we could see with special
gamma-ray telescopes or even trying to
make dark matter here on earth by
smashing particles together and looking
for what happens using the Large Hadron
Collider in Switzerland now so far all
of these experiments have taught us a
lot about what dark matter isn't but not
yet what it is there were really good
ideas that dark matter could have been
that these experiments would have seen
and they didn't see them yet so we have
to keep looking and thinking harder now
another way to get a clue to what dark
matter is is to study galaxies we
already talked about how our galaxy and
many other galaxies wouldn't even be
here without dark matter those models
also make predictions for many other
things about galaxies how they're
distributed in the universe how they
move how they evolve over time and we
can test those predictions with
observations of the sky so let me just
give you two examples of these kinds of
measurements we can make with galaxies
the first is that we could make maps
of the universe with galaxies I am part
of a survey called the dark energy
survey which has made the largest map of
the universe so far we measured the
positions and shapes of a hundred
million galaxies over one-eighth of the
sky and this map is showing us all the
matter in this region of the sky which
is inferred by the light distorted from
these hundred million galaxies the light
distorted from all of the matter that
was between those galaxies and us the
gravity of the matter is strong enough
to bend the path of light and it gives
us this image so these kinds of maps can
tell us about how much dark matter there
is they also tell us where it is and how
it changes over time so we're trying to
learn about what the universe is made of
on the very largest scales it turns out
that the tiniest galaxies in the
universe
provide some of the best clues so why is
that
here are two example simulated universes
with two different kinds of dark matter
both of these pictures are showing you a
region around a galaxy like the Milky
Way and you can see that there's a lot
of other material around it little small
clumps now in the image on the right
dark matter particles are moving slower
than they are in the one on the left
if those dark matter particles are
moving really fast then the gravity in
small clumps is not strong enough to
slow those fast particles down and they
keep going they never collapse into
these small clumps so you end up with
fewer of them than in the universe on
the right if you don't have those small
clumps then you get fewer small galaxies
if you look up at the southern sky you
can actually see two of these small
galaxies the largest of the small
galaxies that are orbiting our Milky Way
the Large Magellanic Cloud and the small
magellanic cloud in the last several
years we have detected a whole bunch
more even smaller galaxies this is an
example of one of them that we detected
with the same dark energy survey that we
used to make maps of the universe these
really small galaxies some of them are
extremely small some of them have as few
as a few hundred stars compared to the
few hundred billion stars in our Milky
Way so that makes them really hard to
find but in the last decade we've
actually found a whole bunch more of
these we now know of 60 of these tiny
galaxies that are orbiting our own Milky
Way and these little guys are a big clue
to dark matter because just the
existence of these galaxies tells us
that dark matter can't be moving very
fast and not much can be happening when
it runs in to normal matter in the next
several years we're gonna make much more
precise maps of the sky and those will
help refine our movies of the whole
universe and the entire galaxy
physicists are also making new more
sensitive experiments to try to catch
some sign of dark matter in their
laboratories Dark Matter is still a huge
mystery but it's a really exciting time
to be working on it we have really clear
evidence that exists from the scale of
the smallest galaxies to the scale of
the whole universe will we actually find
it and figure out what it is
I have no idea but it's going to be a
lot of fun to find out we have a lot of
possibilities for discovery and we
definitely will learn more about what it
is doing and about what it isn't
regardless of whether we find that
particle anytime soon I hope I have
convinced you that this mystery is
actually really close to home the search
for dark matter may just be the key to a
whole new understanding of physics and
our place in the universe thank you
[Applause]
[Music]